yo man it's ready set radio bootleg kev
with the homie wale just shut [__] the
[__] down man
yo just so you know
i know that um you you have a lot of
fans that have come on recently in the
mmg era the first record i ever played
years on the radio was back in the go
mode with bumby
back it wasn't like oh 708 what's up oh
seven man oh seven it's been a long trip
but i want to talk to you about some
wrestling man because i feel like um
uh you hit you you hit me and show me
some love on the bray white interview i
did which i appreciated
um it's just like a interesting time for
wwe right now how you feeling about
about everything that that looks like is
is rolling in wrestlemania right now
you're feeling good you feel sorry they
need us to get all this [__] together
right
they write
they [__] up with the royal rumble and
they fixed it but but it's like that was
this like six pay-per-view screwy finish
like it was terrible it's like the sixth
one in the consecutive with
the [__] that finish like and it's like
so reminiscent of the wcw like last days
yes yeah everything kept [__] up and
it's just like
you want to believe like well we don't
know what we're talking about because
it's a book it's like super hard and
like the center but
logically i just don't see how it can be
like that much harder than like
the millions of people that work for csi
or
saturday live
and whose line is it anyway and problem
you have a direct line with your fans
these days when you know what they want
that's what i'm saying like forums it's
all type of stuff what happened you
should die it died i would just keep it
going for audio that's fine um so uh how
do you feel about
the daniel bryan angle getting him added
into the three-way match and taking away
roman's like official wrestlemania shot
i mean i don't i mean i think they would
have pulled the match because it's been
like
you know roman gonna kind of got that go
like i'm i mean goldberg has more moves
than roman to be true romans and he's
terrible on the money my woman's not a
good mic man and he's not really
necessarily a good hand
and especially if brock was supposed to
give up the title like
they're kind of like uh oh like you know
what i'm saying like he's not he's over
but he's kind of like over like for the
wrong reasons like he's cause he looks
like rico suave and then trying to get
rock to come in and and like put the
band-aid on him in the round yeah you
know that's what they call the rub
they want to rock they give him a rub
but that wasn't that wasn't they did
rock was making the face like oh [__]
this is
bad i think they might have to make
roman go heal at some point they got to
they got to do something just a hill
that powerbomb people through tables and
frowns and
what's his hair everything is just too
much like he has a army like a swat team
thing on like right
he hasn't he's the only guy from the
shield who hasn't changed his uniform
yet he's dean didn't really say
he i mean you know he just went home he
just put some jeans on it and then kevin
went home and came back
straight up man um how do you feel i
know you're a huge sneaker head i want
to know your thoughts on the uh the new
yeezys that uh everyone's been posting
about these adidas like i mean
they're definitely different the thing
is is like this
90 of shoes can be freaked the right way
to me personally kanye like you know
with the way he wears his shoes like
you know what i'm saying he wears them
like kanye west wears a shoe i bet you
i'll get them easy boost i bet you i put
them on like
they're going to go up like the people
like oh they do kind of there's a
hypebeast and it's just like it's not in
the hype like
the lucy goosey like i never tie my
shoelaces everybody knows where i keep
the left one now everybody knows that
like you've seen that [__] come on
everywhere in there people doing it like
it's just the way you know i'm not
saying like i'm saying
i'm the [__] shoe godfather you might
be though yo you're the yo
first clark ken for a small period of
time i was in the lebrons heavy around
the nines and then into the tens and
then they got shitty to me yeah but yo
you're you're the nine god yeah i had a
lot of well it's all uh because you know
dc we wear basketball shoes of course um
you know i didn't even know people
outside of dc didn't wear basketball
shoes until i [__] went to l.a i was
like you wear basketball shoes like
regular shoes everyone's having full
posits on the east coast people like
wearing vans only like the basketball
shoes are to play basketball
you know they wear like vans and
cortezes and dunks and [__] like that so
but um you know i think it's all in like
why you come with i'm gonna get them i'm
gonna give me a pair i bet you when i
wear them i'm saying i know i'm a poster
you're gonna put them over you're gonna
put them over yeah they're gonna you
might put them over here they're gonna
go they're gonna have they're gonna make
a face turn yeah
right yeah because they're getting a lot
of hate and it's like i think a lot of
people are kind of comparing them to the
old ones for sure you could play
basketball on the old ones
not 25 years old anymore kanye's not 31
he's 30 years old he's like he's a fully
grown man with kids and a [__] wife
and just in the job and
like he's over he's got the complete
[__] bro like he's not about to give you
neon [__] souls no more bro like he's
on a battega vanetta [__]
the uh uh uh he was doing versace before
like
like he was already there he did it
already so what you want this man to do
make you another knee on his shoe i did
that i gave you glow in the dark so i
gave you
six pairs of glow-in-the-dark sneakers
like now we'll give you something that's
a little more refined a little more like
adult like the album about nothing is is
this your best body of work absolutely
yes
man because yeah like i said i've been a
fan for loans all the mixtapes i mean i
i even yo man i know like
personally i really was a huge fan of
ambition this was probably my favorite
album
not necessarily body work because
because i i definitely love the mixtape
about nothing but when you when you went
with the album about nothing it
definitely got me excited man but i'm
just gonna do more for my core fans and
the
concept buyers yeah because i feel like
you had a lot of fans that were riding
with you from the jump that kind of you
know you was on the roots album and you
were i don't have a lot of those early
looks i often wonder if um if
me not really having a record like
that's super successful that radio like
a loaded fly among they're like i wanted
i always want to know if lotus had
anything to do with me doing 171 um
i don't think so but i don't think it is
the label thinks it does yeah [__]
and they'd be like well you know we
gotta have another number one for your
album comes out well obviously like i
think that you know i think awareness is
the biggest thing you're you're probably
the first wave of artists that i don't
want to call you an internet rapper but
you were the first wave of the guys that
that i would i got your music off the
blogs i got music online but i you know
things have changed and i went with
maybach and people perceive it a certain
way and they try to take me out of the
conversation because i'm with maybach
like if i would have been
independent you know they would have
proceeded a different way i just went
into the day for my music to be like
received
or like listen to given the same
opportunity as
you know they give a j cole or straight
up okay i want the same opportunity
these are my peers you know these people
i personally have conversations with you
know all the time like you know what i'm
saying like well something i appreciate
personally is i'm a big kanye fan and
specifically i a lot of people act like
kanye just became a [__] [__] but
kanye has always kept it super 1000 and
been super confident but what i
appreciate about you always is that
you've always been a guy who like
speaks your mind 100 you're extremely
passionate about your art if you feel a
certain way you ain't afraid to speak
like step out on it and i feel like
over the last few years you went from
kind of being like the cool it rapper
dude you signed with maybach music you
did like records like no hands and i
feel like a lot of
a lot of them core fans
you know
when guys like you when you're on a
roots album and then you do no hands you
get you know unnecessary shade per se my
first record was
dig dug you had i mean yeah exactly and
nike you had nike boots away i mean [__]
your first time at my gucci mane i was
more rashy i was some more ratchet [__]
back then too
we was the cool nick young [__] that
worked at the shoe store
we got the suburban girls we had hood
rat male friends yeah straight up we was
just in between so well i'm looking
forward to the album
it's coming out what's it what's it
we'll say uh
march 31st wale uh i'm loving i've i
loved the uh the mix tape i'm i'm loving
everything man i really really cannot
wait to hear the album thank you um i'm
looking forward to it my dude i
appreciate you one thing who is your uh
prediction to walk away with the wwe
heavyweight world championship at
wrestle after wrestlemania but it
depends who the i think they're gonna
adjust the main event you think daniel
bryan has a shot
i think they're trying to get some buy
rates cause they [__] up they no i
think they're trying to get some buy
right they gotta put danny bryant in the
main event they gotta they're trying to
they're trying to sell the network they
gotta get by rez he's the most over
wrestler they got they just personally
and the wild card is i'm waiting to see
how the [__] randy orton hasn't come
back yet
he was at a house show from dc i know he
did a house show he came out when it
when when they went dark
well i i i was going to say i don't know
if it's her i think he might be
wrestling an injury though i think and
honestly randy's character was so
[__] tired like this is the best [__]
that probably could have happened to me
so but if you had it if you had to put
money on one wrestler to walk away with
the bell at the end of wrestlemania i
mean obviously we haven't seen faster
than seth might try cash in at the end
of the day
i think he might try cash in whoever
wins he might try cash in and i wouldn't
be mad if seth walked away with it i
wouldn't i mean you know he's having a
bad week but yo yo yo did you see the
pics of them i wouldn't be man i was i
wasn't my son last night at the movies
that was that was
but i don't know he's having terrible
might be a way to get him over more yo
real talk it might be like
my guy i appreciate you
for sure